how old are you 22. [__]
what year is that that you were born
2000 I got to tell you the right huh
yeah
I remember 2000. I thought what was you
doing in 2000 [__] thinking the world
was going to end at my uncle's house on
New Year's Eve
wait no there was a time in 2020 Y2K
thing that was like a thing like you you
wouldn't know but
when 1999 was happening they said when
the clock hit 2000 like all the
computers and [__] in the world were
going to like freeze up and like the
world was gonna like end see they that
it was a time in 2012 but they said the
same thing and I was I was 12. and like
they were like it's going to be this big
storm and all this stuff so it was
actually raining that day so I was
having a panic attack like the world is
overweight I'm only 12. it's coming yeah
isn't there a movie called 2012. I think
there's a movie yeah really
yeah yeah that's what it was that's what
it was what is your sign
I'm a Leo see I don't know what any of
this means so you just asked it did you
so I'm I'm I know I just know I'm an
aquarius okay Leo's in Aquarius they get
along well we get along yeah
who don't you get along with
Scorpios what months are that like I
don't even know I don't I don't pay
attention to scorpions but when you say
your Scorpio it's like is Drake a
Scorpio no Drake's a Libra no
I think he put it out
yeah I think he is Scorpio any Scorpios
in here
nope okay that's good
so if you are like let's say you go out
on a date with a guy and you find out
he's a Scorpio is that a rap
yeah we probably didn't even get along
during the day but what if you did get
along and like everything was going
great and then he was like I was born on
October 24th and then you're like
yeah they're just full of [__] so
probably really yeah they're sneaky like
it probably went so great and I probably
think the world is like pieces and
creams with them but I just know deep
down they're full of [__] really yeah I
you know I didn't know that this existed
like you would like discriminate against
someone you liked because of their I
mean I mean they can't choose that yeah
it depends um
I guess it depends huh it depends on how
good it was like how good the date was I
might consider okay okay okay yeah uh
well listen man uh shout out to all the
Scorpios out there just know she will
discriminate against you yeah and very
bad and if you work at Amazon you're
[__] don't let you work at Amazon and
be a Scorpio that's the double whammy I
might just walk past you uh what what do
you do in your free time right now are
you like streaming TV are you uh working
out are you playing video games what do
you do when you're uh like when you're
not recording or running around the
country pushing your music
um I'm getting into like I love to cook
so I'm trying to start my own little
like cooking
I don't know is it like the reels and
the shows and stuff yeah I'm trying to
you know start doing that I have a dog
we just be at the house I'm kind of
chilling my t-shirt too oh like a little
a little puppy his name is Chase Chase
yeah I like that uh what do you cook
like what's your go-to dish
oh I so it's so funny because I put in a
song of pasta Lobster but it's actually
like my go-to dish now like so the
lobster pasta is what your go-to is yeah
you gotta try it it's so good can you
cook up like any special sort of ramen
noodles like if you were to make a pack
of noodles yeah and you put like the egg
and the shrimp in there and like the
green onions and stuff it's like it's
Ramen yeah some people will put like uh
just hot sauce and like melted cheese
and cheese yeah you never put cheese in
your noodles
y'all put cheese in y'all noodles
I do oh no
you just put like uh so look the you
know is it like a single cheese slice it
could be
friend I don't like that and then look
and then you just stir it and then it
melts into the noodles
I don't like that food then you get
Tapatio hot sauce then some soy sauce
soy sauce too yeah and then you put the
beef pack in
and
and I swear to God I swear to God it's
good I swear that sounds horrible
it definitely sounds like diarrhea
because our screaming
it sounds like prison
it sounds like spread
it is funny because like I didn't know
subconsciously as a kid I was just
making spread the whole time and so I
started to see these rappers put
together their spreads and I was like I
was eating that when I was a kid
shout out to my parents let me eat like
a [__] convict when I was 11. I'm
still trying to figure out what a spread
is so when you're in jail they'll
they'll they'll take like because you
know in in jail there's like limited
stuff you can get your hands on right so
they'll take like noodles they'll take
like sardines or tuna they'll just put a
bunch of [__] together and then they'll
mash it together
right and then they'll cook it and then
it's like a they call it a spread I went
to jail for four days why
show up to court
it was on Memorial Day weekend so so
everybody was on vacation yeah what was
that like and they it was like a it was
actually in Douglasville Georgia and so
like they had everybody
like I just had a failure to appear for
speeding nothing crazy nothing crazy but
I was in there with women that was about
to do 15 years right so it was not fun
I've been to jail twice it's not fun
either yeah